SAY THEY HACKED OUR
DEMOCRACY.
UTTER ONLY ONE WHO IS SAYING
THAT.
LUKE, THANK YOU FOR SAYING
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: I THINK IT'S A
BIG STORY.
2016 BARACK OBAMA AND
HILLARY CLINTON SAID IT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE TO HACK AMERICAN
ELECTIONS.
TODAY SHE ACCUSED PRESIDENT
TRUMP OF SURRENDER TO RUSSIA
WITH WHOM SHE APPARENTLY
THINKS WE ARE AT WAR FOR NOT
DOING MORE TO STOP RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE.
FORMER HILLARY CLINTON
ADVISOR, YOU WORKED WITH HER
AT STATE AND OTHER PLACES.
EVIDENCE JOINS US TONIGHT.
SO, FLEET, WHAT EXACTLY
SPECIFICALLY SHOULD TRUMP BE
DOING WITH THE RUSSIANS.
>> LET'S FORGET ABOUT 2016.
LET'S ASSUME HE WON 50
STATES, 535-0.
SHE CAME OUT OF THE VOTING
BOOTH AND SAID YOU KNOW HE
IS SO GREAT I VOTED FOR HIM.
NOTHING HAPPENED IN 2016.
LET'S LET'S ASSUME FOR A
MOMENT THAT DONALD TRUMP CIA
DIRECTOR.
HIS DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE AND HIS
DIRECTOR OF THE NSA
TESTIFIED BEFORE CONGRESS
AND TOLD HIM PRESUMABLY THAT
NORTH KOREA WAS ATTEMPTING
AND PLANNING ON DISRUPTING
OUR ELECTIONS IN 2018 AS A
PRECURSOR TO 2020 AND THEY
WERE DOING SO WITH THE
INTENT OF DISRUPTING THE
INCUMBENTS AND THEY MIGHT
HURT HOUSE MEMBERS WHO ARE
INCUMBENTS, WHAT
CONVERSATION WOULD WE BE
HAVING THEN?
>> Tucker: HERE -- LOOK, I
HAVE BEEN HERE MOST OF MY
LIFE.
I DON'T CARE WHAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON SAY
BECAUSE THEY ARE DISHONEST
AND STUPID.
YOU REALLY TELLING ME THAT
RUSSIA WHICH HAS A
CONTRACTING ECONOMY AND
POPULATION AND POSITION ON
THE WORLD STAGE A SINGLE
MILITARY BASE OUTSIDE OF ITS
OWN BORDERS IS A GRAVER
THREAT TO THE UNITED STATES
THAN CHINA?
>> FIRST OFF, I DON'T THINK
IT'S WHACK-A-MOLE.
THEY CAN BE SIGNIFICANT.
>> Tucker: WE ARE SUCKING UP
TO CHINA.
OUR BUSINESS SECTOR,
ENTERTAINMENT SECTOR
POLITICAL SECTOR ALL COW KOWTOW
TO CHINA.
WE ARE EXISTENTIAL THREAT
FROM THE COUNTRY IS RUSSIA.
THE FACTS DON'T SHOW THAT
IT'S INSANE ACTUALLY.
>> THE INTELLIGENCE SHOW AND
IT'S INTELLIGENCE PRESENTED
BY DONALD TRUMP'S
APPOINTEES.
REPUBLICAN APPOINTEES.
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
INTERFERE WITH OUR 2018
ELECTION.
>> Tucker: HOW EXACTLY ARE
THEY GOING TO DO THAT.
>> THEY HAVE DONE IT A
NUMBER OF WAYS.
WE LEARNED THEY GOT INTO THE
REGISTRATION ROLES OF SEVEN
STATES PRIOR TO ELECTION
DAY.  HOW DID THEY GET INTO
SONY?
THE NORTH KOREANS GOT INTO
SONY.
>> Tucker: SERIOUS QUESTION.
>> YOU AND I CAN'T TALK
ABOUT HOW SOMEONE DOES OR
DOESN'T HACK ANYTHING.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON,
DEMOCRATS.
>> AFTER TALKING ABOUT TWO
PEOPLE TOOK ON THE DNC.
>> Tucker: CHINA IS THE
PRIMARY OFFENDER WE NEVER
MENTIONED THAT.
DEMOCRATS HAVE PUSHED FOR
YEARS ONLINE VOTING.
THEY THINK IT LYNN CREASE
THEIR SHARE OF THE TURNOUT.
IT MAKES IT EASY BECAUSE
THEIR VOTERS DON'T LIKE TO
GET OUT OF BED AND GO TO THE
POLLS.
>> I'M NODDING BUT I DON'T
AGREE WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: HOW CAN THEY
STILL BE PUSHING FOR ONLINE
VOTING IF WE HACKING THREAT.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S AS
SIMPLE AS ONLINE VOTING.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT MORE
VULNERABLE THAN PAPER
BALLOTS.
>> WHO IS THREAT CHINA.
EVEN IF IT'S HARD AND GOING
TO FAIL WHO IS IN CHARGE.
>> Tucker: YOU WOULD THINK
CAPTAINS OF INDUSTRY.
SILICON VALLEY, OUR
MILITARY.
>> WHO IS NO CHARGE OF
FIGHTING OPIOIDS.
KELLYANNE CONWAY.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
>> WHY WOULDN'T THERE BE A
WHITE HOUSE COORDINATOR.
>> Tucker: WHAT WOULD HE DO.
>> OR SHE.
>> Tucker: SHE BEING PRODLY
ACCEPTED PRONOUN COULD CAN
STAND FOR EITHER ONE.
>> MIKE PENCE FOR AMENDMENT
MOVEMENT HE WOULD TAKE A
WHOLE GOVERNMENT APPROACH.
SPECIFICALLY, YOU HIT A GOOD
POINT WHICH IS THAT THIS
ALSO INVOLVES THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
THIS INVOLVES FACEBOOK.
>> Tucker: I'M JUST SAYING.
>> HE COULD BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND SHARE BEST
PRACTICES.
>> Tucker: FIRST THING YOU
WOULD DO IS SAY NO
ELECTRONIC VOTING IT'S
VULNERABLE TO FOREIGN
HACKING.
DEMOCRATS ARE PUSHING
ELECTRONIC.
YES, YOU WOULD.
>> I HAVE A BETTER SOURCE
THAN YOU.
I WOULDN'T.
>> Tucker: I HAVE BETTER
SOURCES AND COMMON SENSE
WHICH TRUMPS ALL WHICH TELLS
YOU THAT ANY SYSTEM IN WHICH
ELECTRONIC TRANSFERS BETWEEN
TWO POINTS IS VULNERABLE TO
HACKING.
>> ALL VOTER ROLLS ARE
ELECTRONIC ALL RIGHT.
>> Tucker: VOLGT VOTING
ITSELF IN STATES WITH PAPER
BALLOTS IS SAFER THAN THOSE
ELECTRONIC VOTING.
DEMOCRATS ARE PUSHING FOR
ELECTRONIC VOTING EVEN
THOUGH RUSSIA IS HACKING THE
ELECTION.
HOW CAN THAT BE.
>> TALKING ABOUT DIFFERENT
THINGS.
>> Tucker: ARE DEMOCRATIC
VULNERABILITIES.
>> THAT ARGUES FOR THE NEXT
100 YEARS TO USE PAPER.
>> Tucker: YES.
AS LONG AS WE FACE.
>> ENSURE OUR VOTING SYSTEMS
ARE -- HACKING.
>> Tucker: I GAVE YOU A
SPECIFIC THING TO HARDEN OUR
DEMOCRACY AND YOU LAUGH
BECAUSE IT MIGHT HURT
DEMOCRATS.
>> I DIDN'T LAUGH IT'S THE
FIRST THING I WANTED TO DO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: IT'S THE OBVIOUS
THING.
>> LET'S USE THE WORD
SCREWING AROUND OR
INTERFERING.
>> Tucker: HIT ME WITH IT.
>> IF IT'S INTERFERING,
LET'S SAY THEY CAN'T DO IT.
LET'S SAY THEY ARE BAD AT IT
FORGET ABOUT 2016.
HAVE YOU THE PEOPLE OVER
HERE NOTHING BURGER CAMP AND
PEOPLE OVER HERE DOUBLE
WHOPPER WITH CHEESE CAMP.
WHAT SHOULD WOULD HE BE
DOING THAT WE ARE NOT?
IT SEEMS LIKE TOOT PEOPLE
PROTECTING US DO NOT DO
ENOUGH.
STEVE: I THINK EVERY
DEMOCRAT IN CONGRESS EVERY
REPUBLICAN TO SUSPEND ALL
ELECTRONIC VOTING UNTIL WE
CAN BE SURE THE RUSSIANS
CAN'T HACK IT.
THAT WAY WE CAN HAVE TOTAL
CONFIDENCE.
>> WHY DO WE BANK?
GO BACK TO THE FAX MACHINE.
>> Tucker: HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT RUSSIA ALL OF A
SUDDEN.
I LOVE.
THIS I'M THE ONE WORRIED.